Speaker 1: We have so much to talk about today, so
let's get right into it. Last night was a special
primary election in Ohio's 11th District, and it
has ended up as a major, major disappointment for
the activist left. I'm going to give you my
analysis first. We will look at the results.
And unfortunately, I'm reading a lot of what I
think are I would just call them overly dramatic
analyzes about this race from some on the left.
So I'll give you my sense of what I think happened
in a moment. Let's first look at the results.
Again, this was the Ohio special election primary,
the 11th Congressional District Democratic
primary. This was an election to replace
Marcia Fudge, who joined Joe Biden's cabinet.
Now, the establishment candidate, the candidate
anointed by the establishment Democratic Party,
was Shantelle Brown. There were hopes that
activist Nina Turner would come out ahead and it
did not go that way as of this moment. The results
were last updated very early this morning.
So nothing nothing's changed for some time.
Shantelle Brown coming out ahead of Nina Turner
by about six points, just a hair under six points.
Only about forty two hundred votes
separating the two. Remember, this was
a Democratic primary in the 11th Congressional
District, so a relatively small electorate. So
those are the results. And I want to give you
my analysis of what took place. But first, I
want to talk about some analyzes that I think are
just missing the mark here. There are narratives
being pushed about what happened here in certain
circles that just don't make sense to me. I'm not
against these being possible analyzes, but when I
look at them, they don't make sense. One is this
was a racist thing against Nina Turner. Now, if
you look, you would notice that Shantelle Brown,
Nina Turner's opponent who won, is also black. So
it just being racism, which I've seen a couple of
of hot takes, just doesn't make sense to me. So
then when you dig deeper, some people will say,
well, what we mean by that is Shantelle Brown
is not as black as Nina Turner in a lot of ways.
That's a really weird argument to hear people on
the left making it sound sort of colorists to me.
And I understand what they mean by that is that
Nina Turner has more issues of particular concern
to the black community as part of her platform
than Shantelle Brown. But to say Shantelle Brown
is not really as black as Nina Turner. That's
a very weird thing. I can't get behind that.
So then it gets to well, Shantelle Brown had
significantly more white supporters. That's what
we mean. Whites who didn't vote for Nina because
she's black, but they voted for Shantelle Brown
despite Shantelle Brown being black.
That's really weird to me. And again,
most of the district is black. This is a primarily
it's like 53 will look at the numbers and it's
a 54 percent black district. That's that's a
strange thing to say to me, that that doesn't
really make sense. So then another one I'm
seeing is that Israel picked Shantell Brown
and Israel funded Shantell Brown because
Nina Nina Turner is a for Palestinian rights.
This one's also kind of weird. And, you know,
there aren't that many Jews in that district.
It's a mostly black district, 54 percent.
Some of the of the white voters are Jewish and
some of them are Democrats and some of
them voted in the Democratic primary.
So I think what they're getting at is that a
group called the Democratic Majority for Israel
supported Brown over Nina Turner. And that's true.
Now, there's the perception, rightly or wrongly,
that Nina Turner is is like against Israel's
existence. I've not seen evidence of that.
And Nina Turner has denied that. Nina Turner
also came out against the BDS movement, but
she's also against legislation to curb BDS. Nina
Turner said she's OK with military aid to Israel,
but wants it to be conditional. She
tweeted, and apartheid during the last
flare up. And that's that's a controversial
term when it comes to the Israeli-Palestinian
conflict. We don't have to adjudicate it. And
it's just it's controversial in some circles. So
the truth is that that group did support Shantelle
Brown. That's accurate. Now, to go further and say
this has Israel's hands all over, it starts to get
conspiratorial and it borders on an anti-Semitic
trope. This particular group, which is an American
group, supported Shantelle Brown. That's true
to say. Israel picked Shantelle Brown over. Nina
Turner starts to get a little bit anti-Semitic.
So what do I really think happened? I think
that the explanation here is really boring.
I think Ohio Democrats are mostly relatively OK
with Biden ism for now. Now, you might say they
wrongly think Biden ism is good for them.
That's OK. You could you can make that argument,
but as far as they're concerned, I think they're
more or less OK with Biden ism right now and
they pick the candidate that's sort of more in
line with Biden ism. I really think it's that
simple. This is a district that's mostly black,
mostly working class without college degrees,
median household income of 42000.
That's well below the national median.
And they're just sort of OK with a more moderate
approach. It is Ohio, after all. Now, one other
thing. There are claims that Brown went negative
with lies against Nina Turner, but that actually
there was some of that on both sides. There was a
Nina Turner ad in the final days of the race which
claimed that Shantelle Brown is under an ethics
investigation, which was asserted without evidence
now that there may be an investigation, but there
was mudslinging on both sides. So to me, this is
not this incredible crossing the Rubicon Black
Swan type of event. It's really similar to Bernie
versus Biden. I would like the Democratic Party
to be more progressive than the average voter
actually is. If you looked on Reddit and Twitter,
it seemed like Bernie had a lot more support than
he ultimately did. Likewise, if you looked on
Reddit and Twitter, it looked like Nina Turner had
a lot more support than she actually did. Turner
did pretty well. She lost by six in the end. Right
now, this Ohio district is relatively happy with
a Biden sort of Democrat and they elected someone
along those lines. I think it's that simple. And
I'm glad to have my mind changed if folks disagree